do you think that when you were when you
were young you get molested is that why
my life or you turn out like this
I think
that's a huge part of why this happens
yes
because everything goes down like after
that because it feels you're so
it made me feel like
but that's how love was
like because that's all you can say
because I love you yeah there's nothing
nothing that quite replaces the love of
the unconditional love of a parent
well I never had them
never really knew
I remember some parts of it but a lot of
my memories like gone because
I think because of getting beat up all
the time you know so many nuts and stuff
when you hit my hair from who
different man means that
took me to their house and said that
they was wanting to help me but they
really didn't they ended up just wanted
to use my body
maybe clean up and do all kinds of stuff
with girls and people and stuff and boys
but when you don't got nowhere to stay
and it's cold outside and you just get
so tired like when I first came here I I
didn't know what to do so I walked a lot
and then one morning I woke up and I
couldn't stand on my feet because they
told me the people around said that I
had cavi feet and I didn't understand
what that meant because I never heard
that before that's what that's cavi feed
is when you've been smoking crack
cocaine for so long Cathy that you your
your feet just get
so painful that you can't even it hurts
to walk oh they told me that you they
call it that because
that people chased crack all night long
and then they're beginning to hurt but
when I first came down here it was like
I wasn't really changed my life like
because they said this was a place where
they had missions in church and stuff
but that's all life tell me about your
childhood you grew up where I grew up in
Louisiana first and then I ended up like
both not real grandma but I called her
that and
I ended up going to Los Angeles L.A and
she sent me on the bus down to here to
stay with some lady from the church
and she I was just a slave in her own
house like her kids to excuse me back
step in the garage
and
if someone came in they said who's that
lady or who's that girl she would tell
me to
um say hi and be nice
and I just thought be nice to me just
would you like something to drink but
then it wasn't it would be nice man to
you know
take him to the garage and
see what he would ask me
and I didn't get money but I got food
and I got to stay
so so you would go to the garage to do
what to have sex how old were you I was
like 16 15.
where was your where were your
biological parents I don't know the lady
that kind of like raised me they sent me
down here she was a friend of our family
but
I was always like
I don't know I was just born slow I
guess you know
I don't know I would just I wouldn't
talk like
and my mom just like
gave me to the lady
and sexual abuse happened in LA or it
happened in Louisiana it started in
Louisiana with the um my play Grandma's
brother
yeah I would have to do stuff to him
jack him off and let him get on top of
me
I was like 12.
so it's a rough childhood done yeah from
12 all the way and then I come think
America is going to be all Hollywood Los
Angeles California
it was stuff like I seen on TV it wasn't
like that it was all a lie
so I
when I I just ended up like trying to
change but
you just tired hungry and
seeing like the brown person or the
demons would come out and they know
and then I would I would go I'll go with
they asked me if they wanted to take me
to party it was just somewhere to go
because I wanted to get off my feet
once you take a bath you know so you
gotta do what you guys do how did you
come to Skid Row
um someone told me about it like they
said that and then plus I used to see it
on TV like the ladies and the white
uniform and the hats and stuff
tablecloths and dinners and stuff and so
the lady said and Carson she said well
that's where I'm gonna take you because
they got missions and they can help you
get
um help with your mental health and your
they can help me change my life
but then when I came down here I I lost
my purse I lost everything
so
and then people want you to pay for
everything like you came down here what
age
I was like
18 19.
no I was like yeah 1920 19 20. it was
before the summer
but I try not to like
when I think about that I just
makes me more sadder
or it makes me angry sometimes
I go eat to go either way you know it
depends on the day
like my dogs just wandered and then
it's just nowhere to go there's nowhere
to do nothing
but think you know and then all the bad
things that happened comes back
and I get angry and I just go out and
wherever whoever comes up first
I go
let's go that's how you make money yeah
whoever comes first or I try to ask
people to let me clean up the store or
the the front of the stores and stuff
and I recycle
but
then I don't you know
there's only one place to go and they
close down
so I just found out another place but
I don't know when I have all that stuff
it's too hard to carry that you don't
have a tent
I had one but someone stole it
they picked up the whole Channel took it
this lady gave me clothes and stuff
I came back one day one morning because
I stayed out all that night
and um
came back the morning the hotel was gone
so I never got another one
never got another one so I'm just
sleeping on the street
and then
I just ended up just like going to
different places hamburger places that
let you use the bathroom and
I I used to go to Starbucks and sleep
until like they tell me to leave
then that starts my day
and you're trying to make money with the
men down here the men just treat you
like they treat you like dirt they treat
you like they start off nice they start
off oh how do you want to try to drink
you want this you want that
and then as soon as they get you to
their place or in the car they change
like
and it's just like it makes me snap like
two back to the little girl
and I just do what they asked so I could
go
and how much money will you make five
ten twenty I never made a lot but
then this girl told me that I supposed
to ask for a 50 or something 40 or 50.
but when I asked her that they don't
give it to me
and I got raped got beat up
that's why I don't got keys this man's
cycling in the mouth and she called my
whole 14th and stuff and then my other
teeth were bad so that's why I don't got
cheese
do you have children I don't have kids I
had I had a lot of miscarriages
so I don't think I'll ever have kids
because my insides
I assuming miscarriages and three
abortions
when I was younger
that's why the lady sent me took me out
her house because I got pregnant in
Carson
to be our house
kick me out do you know if you have any
siblings
yeah but um
I don't really know where they're at or
you know we're kind of like
if I don't know the lady said I'm the
only child again
I hear other stories you know
I don't know I know I have but I know I
have somebody out there
and then I don't know who my mom
her name is Shirley but that's all I got
who's the last name do you have I have
Jones but who's you know who's her name
is Joan Shirley Jones oh your mom's
[Music]
but I never tried looking for
because she left me
with a lady that I don't even really
know that lady said she's been taking
care of me since I was little six months
I don't remember
I always thought she was my mom but then
she told me I was her granddaughter
and my mom would come back but she never
came back you think you've ever been
loved
I don't know what love is
I don't understand that word because
love I don't know I hear love doesn't
hurt but the only love I ever got hurt
so
I think that's the love
you do what they want or do what you're
supposed to do then people will love you
I guess
I just gotta learn oh how old are you
juicy
huh I don't want to tell my age okay
do you ever have dreams of doing
something with your life
yeah I always wanted to be a beautician
but
they've never had I was young I've never
wanted to do anything else
I just wanted a house and a white picket
fence
that's all smoking crack started for you
win when um I got here not right away
when I got here like after she put me
out when I got pregnant then I came down
here I didn't know anybody and I seen
them doing stuff and then I met this
girl and I sat with her and she
told me what to do and how to do it
and it worked it took all the made me
stop crying and maybe stopped thinking
about the past
and when I go do dates and stuff I I
hope to be higher drunken and it don't
feel bad it doesn't feel it doesn't hurt
like that it doesn't feel bad
so it's kind of like medicine
more like medicine than anything
so
that's about
have you ever been in love
I loved all of them I love I love
everybody
that's all
I never had a real boyfriend or anything
no
do you ever get depressed
are you all the time depressed yeah I
don't mean to laugh but that's why I do
crack it's a stupid question
that's when you have to drink or drink
some drugs or take pills
and then you don't feel as depressed
living Down Here Without a tent
it's got to be so rough especially for a
female exactly I just walk a lot I walk
walk
a lot
what's your greatest strength
oh no
I don't know
do you have any good memories of your of
your life your childhood
no
that's why I say I don't know because
something must have happened when I was
little because I never
I don't remember anything good I don't
remember
playing with my sisters or nothing I
always use this
yes ma'am yes ma'am
that's all I know
they all said they love me but
I don't know if I don't do something
then they get mad
cuz I don't clean right or something
it's all crazy
what would you say is your greatest fear
now
being dying
dying
nobody knows me nobody knows my name
sometime I wish that happened though
like I always I every day I wish like
when it's gonna happen like I don't know
I don't like to wake up right
so I take a lot of people's pills
so maybe I have to take them because I
have to if I don't then I have those
dreams and sweats and
I just start walking I'll get up on
wherever I'm at if I close my eyes then
all the bad stuff comes back
dogs chasing me people hurting me
chasing me all kinds of stuff
like
it's not a life I wish for anybody
do you have any friends now
no
I mean the store people are my friends
the store people wherever I be I just
need to store people they they my
friends
but not these people they're not my
friends because I don't have money
like when they want it or I don't have
crack
you have to give money to get love like
you have to give something to get low
I know that can't just get it up for
nothing
Gotta Get You Gotta Give something
um
Jesse what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
to do what they say do what anybody says
to do so you won't get hurt
I know if you do do right good by the
people or a person
okay it'll be okay
and it only lasts for a little while the
pain the hurt
maybe that's for a little while then it
goes away
because I take medicine
my medicine
it works
it's not like I'm not proud of but
I don't have any other choices
nobody will help you unless I have
something to give but I can't give them
because I have to give myself first
because I got to get tickets get well or
get you know
it's really nothing left so I start all
over again start all over again you feel
like everything in life including love
is just a transaction I think it's all
organic I think it's all a game
I don't know when it's gonna happen or
if it ever will
I really don't care anymore I don't care
no more
I don't know
devil went
that's all
because I think some people say you're
like it's like an army you have the
front Soldiers the captives young you
know how it goes and so maybe I'm just
the ones that are supposed to get killed
like or go through like fight like you
know
like that
all right Juicy thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you